heute rufe ich erneut auf sofortiger
waffenstillstand auf allen seiten
maximale zurückhaltung die rückkehr an
den tisch des dialoges und der
diplomatie
diese dringlichkeitssitzung der
vollversammlung
laut resolution
50 vps gemeinsam für den frieden das
bedeutet dass die führung der vereinten
nationen auch den erwartungen entspricht
dass wir zu unserer primären aufgabe
zurückfinden den weltfrieden und die
internationale sicherheit zu wahren
es ist wichtig dass wir
alles unternehmen um diese situation
einzuhegen und um eine friedvolle lösung
eine friedvolle beilegung finden im
einklang mit dem geist der vereinten
nationen und der vater der nation am
freitag trafen wir uns und es gibt ein
spezialfonds der gelder frei macht für
die humanitäre hilfe denn die folgen für
die zivilbevölkerung gerade für frauen
nur kinder und ältere menschen und auch
andere verwundbare gruppen sind hoch
es gibt auch
viele menschen aus der ukraine fast eine
halbe million die jetzt die ukraine
verlassen und im westlichen bereich der
von europa zuflucht suchen in rumänien
in der tschechischen slowakischen blick
und so weiter
das melden uns die grenz stellen und
diese humanitäre hilfe steht jetzt zur
verfügung meine verehrten freunde es
gibt im krieg keine gewinner
nur zahlreiche leben sagt werden
zerstört
zugang zu humanitärer hilfe
gewährleistet sein exzellenzen die
scharte der vereinten nationen sollte
ist kurz nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
verfasst worden und sie basiert auf dem
grundsatz der souverän gleichheit und es
geht darum dass konflikte immer
friedvoll beigelegt werden ohne
rückgriff auf gewalt
auf die gründer dieser organisation und
ist es einer frau für all das für dass
diese organisation steht die gewalt muss
aufhören
gesetz und völkerrecht müssen beachtet
werden dialog und diplomatie müssen
wieder die überhand die oberhand
gewinnen exzellenzen verehrte kollegin
ob mir schon zu dieser
1946 wurden wir gegründet und in unserer
gesamten insight ist es so
viele kriege in der
menschlichen geschichte nicht verhindert
werden konnten und wir brauchten ein
mechanismus für gemeinsames vorgehen
und es hat hier schwächen gegeben robert
nissel zwei spielen er ist der
ursprüngliche architekt hinter dem
völkerbund
er
hat gesagt dass sie völkerbund tesla hat
dann gesagt jetzt leben die vereinten
nationen wir haben jetzt 76 jahre
vereinten nationen hinter uns und
wir sind gegründet worden um weltfrieden
und internationale sicherheit zu
bewahren und deswegen waren wir
gemeinsames vorgehen wir
brauchen
den friedvolle mitte im einklang mit
gerechtigkeit und für müssen wir
beilegung mechanismen finden für
internationale krisen und situationen
gestern gab es ein
fenster eine eine chance für einen
dialog
verhandlungsdelegation von beiden seiten
treffen sich in dieser stunde in belarus
wir beten dafür dass die gemüter sich
beruhigen und dass man den weg zum
frieden findet die exzellenzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
liegt über alle diese länder hier wir
verstehen uns als das kollektive
gewissen der menschheit wir sind eine
moralische instanz und wir sollten die
welt zeigen dass wir
die kriegsrhetorik nicht schärfen so
dass wir viel mehr dem frieden eine
chance geben wir brauchen humanität
mitgefühl liebe und hoffnung das sollten
wir verbreiten dann geht es uns besser
wir müssen alles dafür tun dass frieden
wieder die oberhand gewinnt
er sagt ich übersetze nehmen sie also
doch
der generalversammlung exzellenten
das kämpfen in der ukraine muss ein ende
finden es tobt im ganzen land aus der
sie vom land und aus der luft und es
muss jetzt aufhören
die raketenangriffe und bombenangriffe
haben die städte durch jede tag und
nacht getroffen die capital kapitale
teams die hauptstadt ist von allen
seiten umzingelt
3 millionen einwohner sind gezwungen
gewesen entweder sicherheit zu hause
suchen in
luftschutzräumen zu gehen oder sich in
der u-bahn zu verstecken
der bevölkerung sind waffen gegeben
worden damit sie sich an der
verteidigung des landes beteiligen
können
eine halbe million
ukraine haben die flucht über die
grenzen des landes angetreten obwohl
die russischen kräfte weitgehend
militärkräfte idee ukraine attackieren
so oder ist leider das signal aus new
york von der uno
zusammengebrochen liebe zuschauer das
natürlich besonders tragisch und
ärgerlich ausgerechnet der jetzigen
situation aber schon ist das signal
wieder da und wir gehen wieder live
deutschen
sie ihre recht das menschenrecht
generell muss aufrechterhalten werden
die unabhängigkeit und herziger der
integrität der ukraine innerhalb der
anerkannte grenzen muss erhalten wir
hätten entsprechenden resolution der
generalversammlung
der präsident wir erleben eine tragödie
für die ukraine aber auch eine
weitreichende regionale krise mit
möglicherweise zeigen dass -folgen
folgen für uns alle
streitkräfte gestern in erhöhten alarm
versetzt worden eine wirklich
ernüchternde entwicklung der einen kalt
wird die gefahr eines nuklearen konflikt
ist wirklich unvorstellbar nichts kann
es rechtfertigen kernwaffen zu selbst
hätte
der präsident
wir stehen vor der schlimmsten
humanitären und glücklich kilo europas
in jahrzehnten
das ist die derzeitige lage ich bin
dankbar dafür dass du viel mitgefühl und
solidarität von den nachbarn ukrainisch
begründet worden wird für die
flüchtlinge diese solidarität muss ohne
unter vier terrasse der religion oder
anderer kriterien auf alle ausgeweitet
werden die nachbarländer brauchen den
nächsten tagen und wochen alle unsere
unterstützung die vereinten nationen
werden dabei ihren beitrag leisten
der präsident ich habe am samstag mit
vielen gesprochen und ihm zugesichert
dass die vereinten nationen dass die
support nicht verlassen werden und dass
wir uns weiter für die pläne einsetzt
werden noch vor den ereignissen der
letzten woche sind drei millionen
menschen auf beiden seiten der kontakt
linie von deflation gummitier versorgt
worden
die arbeiten jetzt tag und nacht als
vereinten nationen daran humanitäre
bedürfnisse zu erfassen und
lebensrettenden der unterstützung für
viele menschen bereitzustellen
die verzweifelt nach obdach und andere
besuchen vor allem frauen kinder ältere
menschen und behinderte wir sind voll
organisiert wir treten dafür ein der
flieder hilfe erhält der von diesen
tödlichen frick den ganzen land
betroffen ist einige unserer mitarbeiter
weil bestimmte programme aus und
bereiten neue operationen vor damit die
bedürftigen möglichst bald hilfe
bekommen ich möchte drei punkte
hervorheben dass die erste mal habe ich
20 millionen us-dollar aus dem zentralen
reaktionshoch für notfälle bereit
gestellt die
maßnahmen entlang der kontakt linie in
der nähe von dann jetzt du ahnst in
anderen teilen des landes wir können
bedürftigen menschen auf diese weise
eine grundversorgung möglichst bald zu
gute kommen lassen
ich habe anita watt als
krisenkoordinator für
kontakte mit der regierung und die
verschiedenen kontaktstellen vor ort im
einvernehmen mit dem team der vereinten
nationen und anderen außerdem haben die
ja auch noch partner in land und
außerhalb des landes und schickte
mitarbeiter in das land dritter morgen
werden wir uns bei koordinierte
notfallmaßnahmen zu gunsten der ukraine
ergreifen auch aufrufe ergehen lassen
angesichts der immer weiter reichende
landesinternen vertreibung und der
flüchtlingskrise
menschen die also die nachbarländer und
hilfe suchen wir fahren unsere jugend
hoch und viel sicherheit der
un-mitarbeiter muss gewährleistet werden
nach dem internationalen recht und die
humanitäre hilfe muss
geleistet werden können
möchte alle auffordern für die
bewegungsfreiheit
sie sorgen damit die hilfe vor ort
geleistet werden fordere die
völkergemeinschaft auch auf
sich um die bedürfnisse aller
vertriebenen zu kümmern wie auch für die
anderer betroffener gruppen deren anzahl
im laufe der kämpfe noch weiter steigen
dürfte herr präsident die humanitäre
hilfe ist von entscheidender bedeutung
aber keine lösung
wir werden nur die schlimmsten
auswirkungen des klubs behandelt die
einzige wirkliche lösung ist der frieden
der angriff auf friede ist ein angriff
auf das völkerrecht das multilaterale
system der charta der vereinten nationen
die folgen sind ganz erschrecken sich
hieraus ergeben könnten die regional
spannung erleben zu
sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergriffen worden
sind noch das greifen wie viel auf dem
spiel steht für alle betroffenen
alles wirkt sich in vielen bereichen aus
und ich möchte jeden mitgliedsstaat
aufrufen sich nach den grundsätzen der
kater zu richten der präsident jetzt
schießen die karton aber das fenster für
einen dialog muss immer offen bleiben
das ist sie zu spät in guter absicht
verhandlungen auf zudem und alle fragen
friedlich anzugehen ich hoffe dass die
direkten gespräche die stadt wenig
inzwischen unterhändlern aus der ukraine
und russland in belarus nicht nur
das kämpfen einschränken können sollten
auch ein weg hin zu einer lösung zeit
werden ich begrüße alle friedlichen
bemühungen das blutvergießen zu beenden
verhandlungen müssen ermöglicht werden
die vereinten nationen sind bereit
solche bemühungen zu unterstützen
herr präsident
der krieg ist keine antwort er bedeutet
tod menschliches leid
sinnlose zerstörung
führt dazu dass wir von den wirklichen
aufgaben der menschheit abgelenkt werden
von der klimakrise wenn das der
biodiversität
hier und der hdmi die uns alle trifft
könnte probleme und vielen anderen
wichtigen fragen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts die landschaft kann es sich
nicht leisten an alle mentalität zu
vermeiden die die kriege des letzten
jahrhunderts wiederholt die vereinten
nationen müssen die geißel des krieges
zu überwinden wir müssen und ob die
wirklichen probleme konzentrieren statt
sich verschlimmern die menschen gehen
auf die straße und verlangen ein ende
des krieges die menschen in der ukraine
wollen den frieden und brauchen hin und
ich glaube die menschen mit der
russischen föderation denken genauso wir
brauchen jetzt den frieden danke
ich danke den generalsekretär für sein
kommentar
das wort und linke sind der
richterin dem vertreter der ukraine das
wort erteilen
präsident
präsident sehr verehrter generalsekretär
for the first time since sie erst mal
seit der gründung der vereinten nationen
böse 5 live erleben
ein krieg mitten in europa jeder in
diesem raum
und jeder auf der welt
weiß dass die russische föderation und
allein die russen riesen diesen diese
invasion
entfesselt hat mit der unterstützung
dieser krieg ist ohne jeden anlass
er ist von jemandem
entschieden worden wir jetzt in einem
bunker sitzt wir wissen genau was
passiert mit dem der in einem bunker in
berlin gesessen hat im mai 1945 mit
meiner stellungnahme fortfahre
es ist mir wichtig auf russisch
fortzufahren und ich bitte sie die
kopfhörer aufzusetzen
ich habe doch ich möchte jetzt sowie
etwas ablesen smartphone auf dem
bildschirm
eines smartphones von einem getöteten
russischen
das ist ein skript von jemandem der
nicht mehr lebt
die karbatsche mutter bürgern jetzt hast
du lange nichts geantwortet wird durch
noch hier sind beim 1 0 war bist du
sicher
fragt die mutter eines ermordeten
soldaten
das war ein augenblick bevor er getötet
wurde mama ich bin nicht mehr auf der
krim
ich bin nicht mehr bei den manövern
engagiert wo bist du denn
das budget muss papa fragt ob es möglich
ist die ein päckchen zu schicken da capo
versuchung was für päckchen mama
was redest du da was ist denn passiert
mama mama ich befinde mich in der
ukraine
hier läuft ein richtiger krieg jetzt
rasch ja ich habe angst
eine biopsie wir schlagen gegen alle
städte ohne unterschied es selbst über
die friedlichen menschen namens ghazali
es sei niemals gut es wurde uns gesagt
dass wir begrüßt werden
aber die stürzen sich unser unser unter
unser panzer und wir lassen uns nicht
vorbeifahren
die nennen uns faschisten
mama mama es ist mir sehr sehr schwer
kurz ein augenblick dann doch wie würde
er getötet
das einfach mal bildlich vorher
die tragweite dieser tragödie
sie müssen sich das folgende
ihrer nachbarschaft
wieso ist es so
es gibt schon mehr als 50
so die platz gilt russian soul mehr als
30 getötete russische soldaten
hundreds of chaos hunderte von getöteten
dariani jubel dutzende von getöteten
kinder los und es geht weiter und weiter
und weiter
an diese die nicht mehr leben
wenn sie jetzt meiner stellungnahme zu
hören
bibliotheken
ein akteur der nach geopolitischer größe
sucht einen krieg entfesselt in einem
nachbarland wörtlich sorgt und williams
herzig rosenthal ganze es gab
bodenangriffe russische truppen haben
die grenzen
aus belarus und aus russland überquert
und auch aus dem don bass und aus der
trennung
das erinnert uns an etwas oder
ganz genau
es gibt hier ganz klare parallelen
man kann da wirklich parallelen zum
beginn durchschreiten welt vergessen und
auch die vorgehensweise von russland ist
ganz ähnlich von dick zu dem vorgehen
der spirituellen mentoren und das vor
acht jahren in st
die gesamte firma brinks hamburger
menschliches leid
kriegsverbrechen
während wir heute hier hingefahren sind
gab es
weiteren raketen abwurf es gab in
kharkiv in wohngebieten
bombenangriffe das ist die zweitgrößte
stadt in der ukraine unschuldige
zivilisten sind getötet und verwundet
worden es ist schwierig eine präzise
zahl zu nennen weil während die
verhandlungen immer noch statt wenn
an der grenze zum belarus
überholt werden die kämpfe fortgesetzt
vielen dank für diese
überwältigende unterstützung
für diesen beschluss dass heute eine
dringlichkeitssitzung
stattfinden kann wir danken dem
präsidenten der vollversammlung dass sie
sich früh darum gekümmert hat
wir schätzen auch das engagement des
un-generalsekretärs hoch denn er hat
wirklich haltung gewesen und er hat sich
für frieden und für die einhaltung der
un vater eingesetzt
wir haben um diese dringlichkeit setzen
gebeten denn die tragweite kann man mit
der tragweite des zweiten weltkrieges
vergleichen oder sogar noch höher denn
putin hat ja die atomwaffen aktiviert
was für ein wahnsinn
denn er sich doch selbst wie darum
bringen möchte braucht er darf jedoch
nicht dass nukleare arsenal zu nutzen er
kann doch einfach das tun was der mensch
in berlin im mai im bunker getan im
jahre 1945
sicherheitsrat hat sich diesem thema
gewidmet und der beschluss ist nicht
durchgegangen aus ganz offensichtlichen
gründe denn das land das seit 2014 die
ukraine besetzt hält hat auch einen
ständigen sitz im sicherheitsrat und das
seit 1991
wir akzeptieren die russische logik
nicht der sicherheitsrat konnte
angeblich nicht handeln weil es hier
eine einseitige haltung gab nein es gibt
nur einen schuldigen hier und das ist
die russische föderation
verehrte dirigierte
russland nutzt sein ganzes militärisches
potential im angriff auf die ukraine die
mundart auch schon reservisten an der
grenze eingesetzt es gibt ballistische
raketen die auf städte abgefeuert werden
es gibt artillerie- es gibt aufklärungs
truppen die wohngebäude schon
entsprechend markieren und zwar für die
dann folgenden luftangriffe roger smith
aus hanau die russischen raketen sollen
die
infrastruktur vernichten gerade auch die
radioaktive entsorgungsstation in der
nähe von kiew und auch invasiv gibt es
ein benzinlager
logistischen ziele wie brücken flughäfen
und wasser behälter gehören auch zu den
russischen
vize städte wie tosca und logan ska sind
fast vernichtet
genau wie wohngebäude in und um kiew und
die russischen kräfte
haben sich auch
im kanal an
genommen und auch
atomkraftwerke und die strahlungswerte
sind in dem umfeld dieser kernkraftwerke
zwei schiffe mit der flagge von panama
und angegriffen worden das sind ganz
flagranten verletzungen des
internationalen rechts
eines dieser schiffe hatte
komischerweise eine russische besatzung
dennoch haben die russen dieses schiff
angegriffen war schon super tag im
kindergarten
weiterhin gibt es angriffe auf
waisenhäuser und kindergärten und
verletzten damit er eigene satzung
krankenhäuser und auch medizinisch
rettungskräfte werden angegriffen es
gibt sabotage gruppen in den städten
es gab anschläge auf rettungswagen in
verschiedenen distrikten versuch von
kiew russische panzer haben einen
zivilisten bus
angeschossen und
rettungswagen sind nicht besorgt es
zugelassen worden schrieb handelsbestand
heute
352 menschen
getötet worden darunter 16 kinder und
2400 ukraine gut in holy war im grunde
sind verletzt worden darunter 45 kinder
und das in den ersten fünf tagen
russischen versionen und diese zahlen
entwickeln sich weiter nach oben
gab es schon bombenhagel
und wir können da noch nicht genau die
zahl der toten beziffern
selbst verteidigung nach artikel 51 ist
aktiviert worden
auch die russischen truppen haben
verluste bei den flugzeugen bei den
lastwagen mehr als 5000 soldaten haben
die russischen streitkräfte in den
ersten tagen schon verloren
ökologie vollversammlung sollte
die russische föderation
auffordern diese angriffe zu stoppen es
und benennen als das was es ist ein akt
der aggression gegenüber einem
souveränen unabhängigen staat und wir
brauchen einen bedingungslosen
waffenstillstand und ein bindungs losen
rückzug aus der ukraine unter beachtung
der international anerkannten grenzen
und
in den bars und volle einhaltung des
humanitären rechts die vollversammlung
sollte auch ganz klar sagen was für eine
kriegerische funktion auch belarus
gehabt hat im zusammenhang mit dem krieg
in der ukraine verehrte mitglieder der
vollversammlung
was sich nun gerade in der ukraine
ereignet
hat
sicherheitstechnisch und humanitäre aus
vermögen für sie alle ganz unmittelbar
für europa ein bisschen später für den
rest im blick auf nahrungsmittel
energiesicherheit
finanzmärkte zusammenbruch der
volkswirtschaft
september letztes jahr sagte mein
präsident in einer rede
und zwar hier in der vollversammlung
nicht die tiere in euren stern wird
gutes essen ich verstehe dass kritik an
der un vielfach geäußert wird aber damit
kritisieren wir uns selbst zitat ende
wenn es uns nicht gelingt jetzt
angemessen zu reagieren dann werden wir
viel größerer kritik ausgesetzt sein
und wir werden dann vielleicht
unbedeutend das darf nicht passieren es
ist jetzt zeit zu handeln und der
ukraine bald zu stehen
es geht um den preis für freiheit und
für sicherheit und wir unabhängigkeit
der ukraine
nicht überlebt dann wird auch der welt
frieden nicht überleben denn die ukraine
nicht überleben kann dann dürfen wir uns
nicht täuschen dann können auch die
vereinten nationen nicht weiter bestehen
die ukraine nicht versteht dann brauchen
wir uns auch nicht zu wundern wenn das
system der demokratie auch schaden nimmt
bitte im namen der ukraine retten wir
die demokratie retten wir die vereinten
nationen und lasst uns die werte an die
wir glauben verteidigen
und für diese werte streiten sich die
ukraine kämpfen die ukraine und bezahlen
diesen einsatz mit ihrem leben
der russische delegierte
wird nun kurz das wort
reifen putin hat alles getan um die
branchen präsent
die russische präsenz in den vereinten
nationen so delegitimieren
branchen präsent united nations herr
selber bin damit aber ich frage mich war
der russische vorsitz in den vereinten
nationen jemals
legitimiert ich gehe so weit zu sagen
dass ich mich frage ob diese bietet
vollversammlung im bodensee jemals im
einklang mit absatz 2 von artikel 4
abgestimmtes mission
was die mission der russischen
föderation
innerhalb der vereinten nationen angeht
weder im dezember 1991
noch im januar 1992
oder in den jahren danach
ich frage sie
ich werde mich an die länder die sich
für eine aufnahme russlands hier
gestimmt haben bitte geben sie die hand
bestätigen sie noch mal dass sie damals
dafür waren dass russland zu dieser zu
diesem organisation gehören darf im
einklang mit der stadt erheben sich
jetzt die hand wenn sie damals dafür
gestimmt haben
es gab ein schreiben von präsident
jelzin im dezember 1991 er damals den
vereinten nationen gesagt russland
möchte gerne
mitgliedsstaat der vereinten nationen
werden als nachfolgerin der
sowjet vielleicht sehe ich nicht richtig
ich sehe überhaupt keine ahnt die nach
oben sich recht ich setze meine brille
auf
niemand hat sich für eine mitgliedschaft
russlands in der vereinten nationen
ausgesprochen und dann lasse ich es mal
dabei bewenden und bitte sie darüber
nachzudenken wenn sie jetzt gleich dem
russischen delegierten ihr ohr schenken
ich danke dem verehrten vertreter der
ukraine
funktioniert
vorsitzender ist herr generalsekretär
sehr verehrte kollegin was linie new
here letzten tage terminiert das
ukrainische im informations feld und
hatten hauptplatz bei der ohne uns auch
jetzt bei der generalversammlung
und dabei werden die handlungen
russlands belogen und falsch dargestellt
und das kommen viele unwahrheiten und es
werden auch dabei die massen legion und
soziale netze einbezogen ich werde jetzt
ausführlich erklären über die gründe
dieser krise und mögliche konsequenzen
ich möchte betonen dass die wurzel
dieser krise und die ukraine liegt in
den handlungen der ukraine selbst die
seit jahren sabotiert hat ihre aufgaben
im rahmen der minsker vereinbarungen
erst vor kurzem bestand die hoffnung
dass die ukraine an dass sich überlegen
und dass sie endlich mal erfüllen werden
das was sie im jahre 2015 unterschrieben
haben
dafür brauchte man in erster linie
direkter dialog mit
aber die nächste bestätigung durch die
oberste führung das land das die
bereitschaft zu diesem dialog und haben
dazu bewogen das den städten also der
höchster status zur verfügung gestellt
wurde uns war wurde das von vorne von
das wäre nicht anerkennung hat uns
endgültig überlegt dass wir nicht kein
recht haben die einwohner von den bass
weiter gleiten zu lassen weil die
ukrainische provokation im februar nicht
nur nicht eingestellt wurden sondern
auch sich verschärft haben wandte sich
die führung und den er an uns uns die
unterstützung zu leisten im rahmen der
bilateralen zusammenarbeit verträgen
heraus beschossen wurden gleichzeitig
wird deren anerkennung das wurde
ökologischer schritt der nicht die
unaufhörlich fortgesetzten provokationen
des ukrainischen regimes die ukrainische
macht die in der letzten zeit aktiv
bewaffnet und auch gehetzt wurde befand
sich erich der meinung dass mit dem
segen der westlichen betreue sie
militärisch das problem von john bass
erreichen können andernfalls kann man
nicht erklären die starke
intensivierung der beschüsse und die
version akten auf dem gebiet der
republiken die ich erwähnt haben die von
der leistung ganz mussten weiterhin den
kellern sich verstecken es stieg die
anzahl der flüchtlinge nach russland
charakter der kooperation hat sich nicht
verändert aber unser zusätzlichen
kollegen wollten nicht merken dass als
sie die ukrainische fabeln wurden
verbreitet dass die von dennis brachte
sich selbst beschießen und die
steigenden leiter der einwohner von den
bass wurde von westlichen staaten
konsequent ignoriert in einer während
eine woche der diskussion dieser frage
fanden sie keine wohl kein mitgefühl für
die einwohner von thomas konto ganz
sieht man denkt diese vier millionen
menschen existieren nicht und im
ergebnis
in angesicht
der einwohner der nähe und wegen der
fehlenden respektive der lösung dieser
frage hat der präsident russlands putin
ein beschluss gefasst über die
durchführung einer sonder einer
sonderoperation die besetzung der
ukraine gehört nicht zu unseren plänen
wir wollen wir wollen die saison weil
diese person seit acht jahren
dem genozid unterworfen werden deswegen
ist es notwendig die militarisierung und
der nazi führung der ukraine
durchzuführen wir werden auch bestrebt
sein vor gericht zu stellen die viele
blutige verbrechen gegen die friedliche
einwohner verübt haben eins ist diese
wurde
getroffen entsprechend im artikel 1 50
dollar und auch auf der grundlage der
föderation versammlung der russischen
föderation ich möchte ihnen angerufen
dass das prinzip der souveränität und
territorialen integrität der staaten an
deren verstoß gegen die dagegen und ihr
vorgeworfen werden ohne dass das wurde
dass dieser beschluss
unverzüglich erfüllt werden bezüglich
der staaten die das prinzip der
gleichberechtigung und auch
selbstbestimmung des volkes und auf
diese weise haben die diese diese diese
es betrifft das gesamte volk was in
einem bestimmten gebiet wohnt unabhängig
von nationalität und rasse aber die
ukrainische jetzige regierung hält sich
dies im prinzip nicht an und deshalb
erfüllt die russische regierung das
recht zur selbstverteidigung eines
staates vor einem staat der bestrebt war
atomare waffen zu besitzen der präsident
hat das erklärt selbst bei einer
sicherheitskonferenz und diese erklärung
des präsidenten wurde mit applaus
empfangen
deshalb sucht die ukraine ein platz bei
der nato und hat der rhetorisch
ansprüche an russland deshalb
russland verteidigt sich nicht nur vor
einer nationalistischen gefahr sondern
stellt wieder die prinzipien der herrin
auf dem territorium von dollars und der
ukraine und auf diese weise erfüllt die
aufgaben die wichtigsten darauf der zur
vermeidung des dritten weltkrieges ich
möchte dabei auch die äußerst negative
rolle der vestischen koalieren beton mit
den vereinigten staaten von amerika an
der spitze
anstelle die ukrainische regierung und
zu bewegen das zu erfüllen haben sie im
gegenteil die echt er gehetzt und die
behaupteten dass diese bestimmung neben
russland nicht erfüllt die nicht einmal
deren partei ist mir noch die westlichen
kollegen haben ohne scham viele waffen
in dieses land geschickt und die
militärischen ausbildung haben sie
praktisch dazu gestoßen dass sie und
andere dass sie eine
streitmacht von 120.000 soldaten bleibt
wenn wir dieses thema hier besprechen
dürfen wir einen breiteren kontext nicht
außer acht lassen
dass entstanden in
das entstand bereits beim gipfel in
bukarest hat was ist ein päuschen
gewarnt dass die mitglieder der allianz
mehrfach sich überlegen müssen bevor sie
ukraine und georgien in die nato
aufnehmen das wolle brötchen dargestellt
dass dieses kompromiss von deutschland
und frankreich
erreicht wurde dass sie ein kompromiss
an stelle unverzüglich die zu mitglieder
zu erklären deren das recht auf beitritt
zu verwirren dann wurde auch von nato
angeheizten präsident saakaschwili und
1900 2014 kam es zu einem blutigen
verfassungswidrigen umstürzten tief in
dessen folge nationalisten und radikale
die macht übernommen haben und die
hatten den kurs auf den kampf gegen
russland auch liegt für uns ich komme zu
diesem thema noch zurück für uns
beitritt der ukraine der nato ist eine
rote linie aus strategischen gründen die
unterbringung der infrastruktur der nato
wurde und die antwort maßnahmen zu
treffen die russland und nato an den
rande des krieges bringen würden deshalb
haben wir
21 vorgeschlagen einen vertrag
abzuschließen damit wir ganz der
sicherheit haben bekommen werden aber
unsere ausgestreckte hand wurde
abgelehnt hochnäsig abgelehnt es wurde
uns vorgeschlagen wichtiger aber zwei
tragende fragen zu besprechen die diese
eigentliche frage nicht
aufheben und dann wurden uns auch
erklärt wie dieses prinzip der offenen
allianzen mit den anderen prinzipien
verbinden jetzt sehr geehrter kollegen
was sollen wir jetzt tun stellt sich die
frage und wir soll die rolle der uno
spielen ich bin sicher die uno soll
diese rolle spielen sie ist in der lage
die verschiedene positionen näher zu
bringen und die schlüsselrolle
entsprechen dem statut soll ich hier der
sicherheitsrate uns spielen aber die
versuche diese frage ruhig zu besprechen
diese versuche werden gar nicht nur
unternehmen aus diesem grund stimmte
russland am 25 februar gegen ein
russisches projekte resolution und gegen
diese und auch an die ukrainische
projekt warum einzig russisch und warum
ein ukrainisch ich sage und man braucht
nur das dokument genau anzuschauen denn
es richtet sich dieses dokument gegen
die ukraine man versucht die macht dort
zu verankern die die tragödie die seit
acht jahren dort andauernd zu verankern
endgültig zu verankern wichtig ist nicht
das was im projekt vorhanden ist sondern
das was dort nicht erwähnt wurde wenn
die verfasser versucht hätten das
richtig zu machen so würden sie nicht
ausklammern die fragen die wichtig sind
für das ukrainische problem zum beispiel
ausgeklammert wurde die frage wieso die
die anti bach gekommen es sind die
beiden unter die 2014 durch umsturz an
die macht kommen sie und die haben die
friedliche viertel aus kanonen und
artilleriegeschossen verschossen
ausgeklammert wurde die frage wie die
ukrainische machte mit unterstützung der
westlichen betreuern die minsker
vereinbarungen nicht erfüllt hat und
dabei die an der kontakt linie
untergebrachten ukrainischen würden die
aus den radikalen und neonazistischen
bataillons methodisch dank für taktik
wohnviertel von der länder beschlossen
haben und dabei haben sie frauen und
kinder getötet das kommt immer weiter
und ich muss auch erwähnen das
verbrechen das bei einem das blut in den
adern zu erhalten lässt über die
verbrennung der menschen im
gewerkschaftshaus genau das
regime hat
das hat die schuldigen an der tragödie
schuldigen an der tragödie oder das
verstecken sich gar nicht die
geständnisse der schützen und andere
bestehen selbst ein dass das in folge
eine provokation
wir haben im letzten jahr auch über
diese fragen eine extra sitzung des
un-sicherheitsrates
wollen durchgeführt aber wir haben nur
die typische
klischees der propaganda propaganda
gehört und das welche es wäre wichtig
wäre in so eine resolution die richtige
bewertung der rolle der westlichen
kollegen die diese krise fragt es
unterstützt haben die haben nicht nur
hinter diesem stoff dann sondern die tat
plant der ukrainischen regierung aus
stellten das was unmöglich ist für jeden
zivilisierten stadt hier ist auch die
diskriminierung der russischen sprache
auch die sie dies
auch die erklärung zu helden die
verbrecher anstelle der echten helden
der reine auch die spaltung des landes
die meydan machthaber um nationalisten
haben
straflos politische opponenten beseitigt
die opposition verfolgt oppositionelle
fernsehkanäle geschlossen aus denen man
wenig klein bisschen objektive
information bekommen würde sechs solcher
fernsehkanäle wurden allein als zu
zeiten von präsident george williams
geschlossen und dann wurden viele waffen
gebracht und danach wurden aus dieser
waffe die einwohner von basket die
verantwortung für das was hier geschieht
liegt nicht nur auf der ukrainische
jubel sondern auch auf den westlichen
mächten sehr verehrte
kollegin ich möchte betonen dass um die
russische sonde operation eine blase von
lügen und verleumdungen auch
durchgeführt wird die westlichen
massenmedien ohne scham gegeben das was
von den ukrainischen regierung zerstört
werden für folgen unserer
sonderoperation wir hören ständig lügen
und tipps über die zerstörung der
ukrainische städte schulen kindergärten
die russische armee bedroht nicht die
friedliche einwohner der ukraine
beschießt nicht die städte die städte
die unter die kontrolle der russischen
streitkräfte gekommen sind leben weiter
ganz normal es wird dort funktionierte
verkehr verkehr und auch alles und das
betrifft auch das atomkraftwerk von
tschernobyl
es wird patroulliert gemeinsam mit der
sonderpolizei ukrainische sonderpolizei
und auch der russischen streitkräfte das
akw von tschernobyl funktioniert
reibungslos
die gefahr für die einwohner der ukraine
sind die ukrainische nationalisten die
die einwohner der
ukraine zu geiselnahmen und sie als
lebendes schild benutzen es gibt
informationen dass die
nationalisten unterbringen schwere
waffen und salven
kanonen in den wohnvierteln das ist eine
himmelschreiende verletzung des
völkerrechts es muss verurteilt werden
im grunde ist das die gleiche taktik die
auch die terroristen von idil immer
wieder einsetzen die gesamte
verantwortung für die möglichen folgen
liegt auf dem majdan regime auch die ein
bewohner der ukraine werden bedroht
durch die
luft die verteilung von waffen und durch
die verbrecher die aus den gefängnissen
freigelassen wurden und diese waffen
schießen bereits und sie befinden sich
in den händen dieser verbrechen das
wissen wir auch von den einwohnern von
key von ander städten das demonstriert
die gedankenlose das einstellung
gegenüber der fbs leben dem leben der
wir haben jetzt einen brief bekommen von
einer bürger organisation und diese
bürger organisation informiert seit acht
jahren die internationalen strukturen
wie in der ukraine
neonazismus entstand und wie er sich
festigte und wie er von der staatlichen
organ unterstützt ein kurzes kurzes
zitat jetzt erleben wir die abo jede
schrankenlosigkeit der nazis die
regierung hat verbrechen aus den
gefängnissen freigelassen die und
alleine in kiew wurden
25.000 maschinengewehre verteilt es
kommt jetzt kam es zu morden zur
plünderung und die idee ist so genannten
vertreter
vertretern der ukraine haben zynisch ein
fahrzeug angeschossen in die ganze
familie kann zu tode zwei kinder
befinden sich im krankenhaus die eltern
und ein kind wurden witterten die
jetzt tut ihn auf der frühjahr als
präsident war hat alle aufgerufen hat
die russen umzubringen im ganzen land
und dabei ist es nach der letzten
wurde festgestellt dass in der ukraine
nach der volkszählung
wurden haben sie in wirklichkeit viel
mehr zurzeit in den massen netzwerken
wird eine informations krieg entfesselt
und
weil es keine erfassung der russische
aktien vorhanden sind werden die
ukrainische schläge und die
ausgegeben die in wirklichkeit die
verbrechen der ukrainische nationalisten
infizieren in den netzwerken werden auch
anweisungen gegeben wie man sie fix
liquidieren kann zurzeit befinden sich
in den massenmedien 1,2 millionen fakes
und auch das was der ukrainische
vertreter vorgelesen hat
dieser briefwechsel eines russischen
soldaten mit seinen eltern dass es auch
das produkt eines fix wir haben gestern
auch nicht unterstützt dass dieses
projekt heute bei der sitzung der
generalversammlung vor gedacht und dabei
dieses projekt des dokuments das gestern
verabschiedet wurde nicht in der lage
ist die eigene verantwortung für die
erhaltung des friedens und der
sicherheit weiter zu bewahren es wurde
nicht mein versuch unternommen eine
konstruktive lösung zu finden die der
versuchte die position russland zu
ignorieren dass das widerspricht dem
sinn der sicherheitsrat und man soll das
nicht weiter durchsetzen sondern man
soll nicht ignorieren sie haben
ignoriert unser legitime sowie im
zusammenhang mit der politik der nato
und der verletzung durch die westlichen
grenze viele länder prinzip über die
unteilbarkeit der sicherheit zum schluss
möchte ich sagen russland hat keine
kampfhandlungen angefangen diese
kampfhandlung mit begann die ukraine
gegen die eigenen einwohner gegen die
bewohner von den massen gegen alle mit
dieser macht nicht einverstanden sind
russland hat diesen krieg zu ende
geführt ich danke
dem verehrten vertreter der europäischen
union das wort
aber die ehre wie die union und ihre
mitgliedstaaten
schließen sich an diese erklärung hier
an
präsident ich danke dafür dass wir uns
heute jeher haben kommen lassen ich
danke auf dem leeren kasse entschieden
ist und ihn kollegen dass sie gekommen
hat es ist ein friedlich wichtig dass
die fakten gehör finden und voll
verstanden werden und dass dieses
gremium in der lage ist angezeigt
entscheidungen zu treffen nachdem der
sicherheitsrat auf großes wegs durch ein
4 1 vom trekking den rat daran gehindert
hat eine diesbezügliche entscheidung
getroffen express im juni möchte zuerst
einmal die uneingeschränkte solidarität
und unterstützung europäischen union für
die ukraine zeigt erfolg
wird gegen eine nicht provozierte ist
nicht gerechtfertigt die blitzaktion
durch russland sich seit der letzten
woche wird zum hier hat er seine
schreckliche eskalation gegeben trotz
unermüdlicher die kroatische regierung
auch auf höchster ebene
beschlossen sich vom frieden abzuwenden
von der regelbasierten internationen
ordner
der uno-charta festgelegt ist auch nicht
nach den regeln der diplomatie
der angriff auf die ukraine hat schon
viele tote und verwundete und vertrieben
nachgezogen die verurteilen in
schärfster form die nicht provozierte
und version wenn der ukraine durch
kräfte der russischen föderation und der
verletzung der unabhängigkeit der
souveränität und der theologe und
integrität ukraine die verurteilen auch
die teilnahme von petrus an im angriff
sie fordern beide staaten auf ihren
nationalen international richtung
nachzukommen die sind auch beunruhigt
über die anhebung der nuklearen watt
sperre durch russland sie möchten
bringen dazu auffordern sofort zur
vorherigen alarmschwelle bei nukleation
a zurückzukehren
und auch
die verpflichtung die matur vertrag zu
denken russland ist oder ein geschenk
für diese erkennung verantwortlich wie
die zerstörung
das militär master haben sofort ohne
bedingungen beendet und dass das gesamte
material aus der gesamten ukraine in die
international anerkannten grenzen
zurückgezogen die fordert größen und
auch ernsthaft einen
dialog dem ziel einer lösung aufzugeben
das vorgehen russlands hat das
völkerrecht verletzt und verstößt
ebenfalls gegen den feind in aktionismus
sagt hellwig ii und die gezielten
verspricht russland souveränität und
territoriale integrität zu achten nach
dem budapester behandlung von 1994
man sagen kann die schlimmste aggression
in europa seit dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs sie folgt ähnlichen
russischen aggression gegen nachbarn
2008 und 2040 zitronen unterstreichen
unsere nachdrückliche unterstützung für
die souveränität und integrität von
georg und
verfolgen die lage in der region genau
diese versammlung hat die aufgabe sofort
und
das handeln russlands berücksichtigen
darauf zu handeln sonst würde das
vertrauen untergraben
interessierte installation der orden ich
wäre die falsche botschaft gewählt dann
könnten solche aggressionen fortgeführt
werden und solche risiken könnten auch
für andere staaten in der region und
anderswo entstehen
wie er die klagen der verluste von
menschenleben
das gros die wirklich kannten die
bedürfnisse der menschen dort nehmen
immer weiter zu die notlage und hilfe
ist eine priorität im großen paket der
eu ein tag mit licht und leisten
dringend benötigte humanitäre hilfe für
die bevölkerung der ukraine sie haben
unserem spiel schutzmechanismen und
heraus direkte hilfe
grüner sind individuen die vg flohen und
liebe auch dort live musik soforthilfe
aufgrund der katastrophe die die
invasion der us bürger
auch das internationale humanitäre recht
die zivilisten und die strafgebühr wirst
du geschützt werden
müssen auf den gleich
von russland unterstützte formationen
auf ihre der situation
cyber angriffe einzustellen wir beklagen
sehr die beteiligung von mails an diesem
angriff und wir rufen das land auf
sofort die internationale ächtung
einzuhalten wir unterstreichen unsere
uneingeschränkte
unverbrüchliche verbundenheit mit der
ukraine und erkennen die ukraine in
ihren grenzen weiterhin
un mitgliedsstaaten aufgerufen werden
die beiden selbsternannten
gebilde nicht an
das sind die wehrtechnische gebildet
wird instanzen sind und hier wollen wir
attraktive maßnahmen auch gegen belarus
in diesen dicht ergreifen der präsident
muss klar sein die glauben fest gerade
das geräusch anwendung und zwar zur
änderung bestehender ordnungen im 21
jahrhundert keinen klatsch aus gusterath
erinnert werden dass die un-charta
verbietet dass gewalt angedroht wird und
gewalt
daten von bewegungsdaten
das entspricht gegen die grundsätze die
faszination die spannungen konflikte
müssen über den trialog und mal
durchchecken
anregungen die un und andere partner
haben unvergleichlich gebühren
lösung zu finden russland hat diese
bedingungen nicht wertgeschätzt
stattdessen einseitig eine
schwerwiegende kurve dachte eskalation
begonnen nach diesen einseitigen
schritten isoliert russland sich nach
weiter selbst wir stehen heute an einem
entscheidenden geschichtlichen
augenblick nach so oft in der
vergangenheit hat die völkergemeinschaft
nicht hingeschaut oder hat zu langsam
reagiert werden
ganze generationen sind an vielen
stellen der welt und sie vertreten viele
von ihnen wie kenner betroffen gewesen
und zahlen für diese untätigkeit die
dürfen das nicht wiederholen wir müssen
jetzt etwas tun nach dem veto russlands
und sicherheitsrat letzte woche muss die
generalversammlung ein das starke
einheitliche botschaft und russland
gehen lassen minute später auf
forderungen die militäraktion sofort
einzustellen die truppen abzuziehen und
sich für einen wirklichen dialog
auszusprechen berufen russland auf
insbesondere alle maßnahmen zu vermeiden
die die sicherheit und
arbeit infrage stellen schon nach
und nach den entscheidungen beurteilen
wie wir hier auf dieser den besonderen
dringlichkeitssitzung ergreifen die
aufgabe nach besten kräften die karte
variation und die welt orden zu
verteilen wir hoffen dementsprechend
dass diese versammlung
fast einstimmig die resolution der
ukraine die einfahrten unterstützen wird
die eu und ihre partner werden alles tun
um die integrität des reparierten
internet systems auf dich zu erhalten
die grundlage unserer sicherheit und
alle staaten sollten gäben zu verfassen
wir werden an der seite der ukraine
stehen
die dort demokratisch gewählten
institutionen unterstützen und ihr
vertreter sowie das ganze volk auch
durch weitere politische finanzielle
humanitäre und logistische unterstützung
viel
liebe kollegen
[Musik]
das wort und zwar im namen des baltikums
conti kehre in nrw nacht leer ist
brechen estland finnland
schweden und ich spreche auch im namen
meines eigenen lange neue adresse in der
nacht
hat die russische führung entschieden
diese version der ukraine
die mitgliedstaaten diese organisation
und das ist ein mitglied dieser
organisation zu insolvent justus camier
sounds simpel wie sehr viele blieb und
mitgefühl wir sehen wie ungerecht dass
es wie sehen das die ukrainische
bevölkerung kämpft ihre städte für ihre
familien sie verteidigen ihre zukunft
machen ihre familien und ihre freiheit
diese soziale öffnete
begreifen die territoriale
unversehrtheit der ukraine an liebe
ships aktion stellen die besten paare es
gibt hier eine große verletzung des
rechts und der größe der un charta und
genau dieses büchlein enthält die un
charta das ist eine antwort auf diese
organisatorin rich in der vergangenen
woche die zweite russische zuhören
entschieden dass sie ja ukraine das
selbstbestimmungsrecht dabei lag das
darf nicht so
russland hat gedacht dass wir schwein
und aber nein wir lassen uns nicht zum
schweigen
wir sind auf der seite der ukrainerin
konsequenz aggression kolonie von juror
bei jedem rennen folgen und nicht nur
für die ukraine und europa
es wird zur langfristigen negativen
das ganze und dreimal hier antwortet
lasieren clique regelbasiert ordnung
es ist so viel leid leben viel
vernichtung zivilen bereich holding im
raum hier sehen wir die kämpfe in den
ständen und ihm auch im großraum von
städten gibt sehr viel leid und sehen
bei der cebit verbringen herr präsident
jedes instrument in unserem rechtsstaat
krippen st und sind schon aktiviert
worden
[Musik]
skandinavische länder
wären auch dem in rheine militärische
unterschiedliche profile und sonaten und
freunde wir grünen haben sich unsere
allianz dazu gesellten und überlegen wie
sie mit livestream können herr präsident
wir watch the throne tagen mit diese
fragen die schlimme forschung
familien getrennt wurden
zu finden sind haben die wahl kinder
halberg
wurden
in diesem unmoralischen krieg auf
zivilisten attackiert werden
hier überhaupt keine grundsätze beachtet
werden das geht ja einfach
das nackte rechnen
wir brauchen
von humanitären massive listen müssen
sodass wir fordern russland auf diesen
sinnlosen schütze der endung wiedemann
und visuell generation und er schon
gesagt hat wir brauchen einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand geworden in russland
auf sofort die truppen abwechslung und
zur großen fahrt des dialogs zu finden
ministerpräsident lassen sie mich das
umladen worden sagen jeder tod eines
zivilisten jedes kriegsverbrechen wird
erfasst
das
täter zur rechenschaft
geschichte schaut uns so will und jeder
restliche pfad wird genutzt werden
die ironisch und absurde behauptung
russland dass es
hier zu ermitteln diese
werden von ihrer aufgabe gerecht und
werden alle verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit und alle kriegsverbrechen
erfassen und dagegen vorgehen monitoring
verbrechen die auf dem territorium der
ukraine stattfinden
kollegen die regelbasierte
internationale ordnung
sagt dass wohnt man miteinander reagiert
das ist
der schlimmen erfahrung des zweiten
weltkrieges entstanden und der
dass sich das nicht wiederholt der
angriff in der ukraine der russische
invasion
hier wäre die prinzipien der un startete
mit 75 jahren
simply be ok tober ruderman capital
partners hat ein veto gegeben jetzt ist
das thema in der hand der versammlung
user gebiet ohne märz russland hat und
sein vetorecht ohne scham genutzt und
das ist nicht zu akzeptieren
russland hat einen ständigen sitz im
sicherheitsrat und hat damit eine
besondere aufgabe soll wahrung des
friedens und darf nicht die eigentlichen
grundsätzlich den schalter
wir brauchen eine reform im
sicherheitsrat
wir nutzen die stärken
der isolierung blühen und sich
weiterentwickeln ein starkes signal
zwischen flächen und sowohl das wir
heute sagen
wie wir die resolution verabschieden das
wird ein signal auch für die ukrainische
bevölkerung seien sie schauen uns wo wir
hoffen die welt sich auf die seite der
un-charta kollegs stellt und die sonne
sprechen euro ist ein bluetooth arm
dieser illegale brutale belüftete
angriff auf die ukraine hat eine
auswirkung auf ihn und jeder
zusammen
und wir müssen auch an zukunft und
verbrechen egal auf welchem kontinent
nur der letzten woche vom braten der
machtvolle stellungnahme von youtube
afrika nach europa in amerika wird das
ist
nicht das geld nicht dieses verhalten
russlands gegenüber einem
lang in der un nicht akzeptiert werden
kann
die branche ist ob schweiz in russland
die angriffe augenblick gibt es keinen
krieg mehr wie noam ben die ukraine auf
insgesamt gibt es keine ukraine meter
stand auf einem plakat das sowohl
hamburg hat das ist eine einfache
wahrheit belarus und russland wird von
der welt zur rechenschaft gezogen
russland ist der haupt aggressor und
belarus macht das ganze möglich
herzlichen dank
die
präsentierten vertreter frankreich das
wort missio präsident
[Musik]
zerstörerische tätigkeit in mosport in
rhetorik totale kriminelle handlungen
nach wie vor dem hintergrund einer
gefährlichen restauratorischen depressiv
russland
damit gegen die grundsätze der charta
der vereinten nationen
respekt von rudi die mittlere der
installation müssen diese karte
einhalten
sie darf geht um eine resolution des
sicherheitsrats
es geht darum dass wir
deutlich machen müssen dass ich um die
bürger die ukraine geht die bürger auf
allen kontinenten haben auch von
russland verlangt dass sofort die
angriffe auf gehört werden dass die
russische mir aus der ukraine aktion
gesät und dass die bemühungen
unterstützt werden die
darf die resolution in der er verlangt
jedoch russland die aggression die zu
ende bringt durch die souveränität und
territoriale integrität des landes der
ukraine erachtet wir möchten alle
mitglieder der versammlung aufrufen für
den sektor stimmen neben der ukraine
geht es generell um die verteidigung der
kater und die existenzgrundlage den
vereinten nationen das muss klar sein
angesicht der bewaffneten aggression auf
1 folgen angesichts der zivilen opfer
ihren zahl jeden tag steigt angesichts
der
doch dafür müssten außerhalb ihres
landes
enthaltung keine option wer sichert
stimmt
die macht das gesetz bestimmt das recht
bricht wir müssen uns für das recht
einsetzen es ist er nach kurt
diese
besondere dringlichkeitssitzung wird
nicht dass es im sicherheitsrat es
ablehnt seiner verantwortung
nachzukommen der rat wird sich am
heutigen nachmittag noch treffen um die
humanitäre lage in der ukraine zu
erörtern frankreich und mexiko
ein resolutionsentwurf vorlegen um dafür
so dass der schutz der zivilbevölkerung
gesichert ist und das
ungehinderte zugang für humanitäre hilfe
ermöglicht wird erst nach dem
eigentlichen bedarf
frankreich
den schultern schulter an der seite des
libyschen volkes das vereinte königreich
hat bereits 1900 millionen anhand ihrer
hilfe versprochen frankreich wird auch
eine rolle
dass die internationale reaktion sich
gegen die vernunft und begangene
aggression wenn
dort gerade im ersten halbjahr der pro
wirtschaft
einzuschränken schrieben sich auf den
kauf von
für die ukraine frankreich unterstützt
den mut erfüllung
die ukrainische bevölkerung der beweis
stellt wie fordern die versammlung auf
den ukrainern unverzüglich unsere
unterstützung zu bekunden durch annahme
der resolution danke
franz
ich danke dem vertreter frankreich
die vertreter des vereinigten
königreiches er ganz schön wort geworden
zuviel erregtheit zu viel hysterie zu
viel fake news was wir brauchen ist ein
journalismus der uns orientierungshilfen
anbietet antrages fundiert und relevant
und genau dafür steht
[Musik]